(Musique )
ça va ou quoi
alors comme sa on apprécie les anecdote
Des anecdotes par ci des anecdotes par là mais ça n'en finit plus
Les amis j'ai puisé dans les fins fonds de mon cerveau
pour me souvenir de trucs que.. J'avais vraiment oublié, à la base.
Vraiment !
C'est fou, YouTube fait de moi un surhomme !
Aujourd'hui les amis ! Il y a du gore, il y a du mignon, il y a du rigolo.
Bref, tous les adjectifs sont employables face à ce que vous allez écouter, et voir.
Êtes-vous prêt ?
Ouiiiii !! [acclamation de foule]
Les amis, on sait tous ce que c'est d'être en CM2.
D'avoir onze ans, d'avoir son premier poil de couille, messieurs.
On en est fier, plus fier qu'un 20/20. Ne nous mentons pas ... ;)
Mais quand ce poil pousse, il te dit : "Elles sont où les meufs, là ?!"
Alors, moi j'avais trouvé ma dulcinée !
Elle était sexy, raffinée ! Comme dirait Lartiste !
[Passage de Lartiste] elle est sexy raffinée...
Mais un autre homme était sur elle, si je puis me permettre.
Un autre enfant, plutôt.
Et il s'appelait.. Alexandre ! [Musique dramatique]
Alexandre draguait cette fille, à la cours de récréation.
Et moi, caché, tamisé dans l'ombre, je voyais cela sous mes yeux.
Ca me rendait très énervé !
De plus j'étais très triste pendant les heures de cours, pourquoi ?
Car il était dans sa classe, et moi pas !
Bref, après six mois de GALÈRE !
Je sors avec cette fille. [Musique angélique.]
*Inspiration*
C'est-à-dire qu'on s'tient la main, pendant les semaines A..
Et pendant les semaines B, elle tient la main de cette autre personne..
Euh.. Que j'emmerde !
Douze ans sont passés, mais rien n'a changé sur ce que je ressent, ok ?! *rire*
Bon. Plus le temps passe, plus elle oublie cet autre individu pour euh.. Penser à moi à la place.
Il est vrai, on s'envoie des Wizzs, sur MSN.
Il est vrai, j'ai la chance d'habiter pas trop loin de chez elle, et on rentre ensemble, de l'école.
Il est vrai, elle commence à m'inviter chez elle, petit à petit.
Il est vrai, j'ai que onze ans à ce moment-là.. Donc NON on va pas baiser ! C'est bon, arrêtez !
Mais lorsqu'on a onze année, on est dans la recherche.. *inspiration*
Du smack.
[En chuchotant] Et je parle pas du céréales, ok ?
Je suis chez ma dulcinée, lorsqu'elle m'invite à monter au premier étage.
[En chuchotant] Dans sa chambre.
Une fois là-haut, je suis à la fois très heureux, et à la fois, complètement paniqué.
Mais ce sont deux sentiments qui ne vont pas du tout ensemble !
Parce qu'ils créent tout simplement, un état de paralysie.
Comme si il y avait un mauvais sort !
On s'assoit tous les deux, sur son lit.
... Arrêtez de croire qu'il va se passer des choses !
On regarde tous les deux en face de nous, et on ose pas se regarder. *rire pas ouf*
Elle décide de faire le premier pas.
Bon après, son premier pas il était pas ouf.
Elle s'appelait Audrey.
Audrey si tu regardes cette vidéo, ton premier pas, il était pas ouf.  *rire*
Nan mais qu'on soit clair !
Elle marche vers son bureau, qui est en face de nous.
Elle y trouve des post-its.
Elle prend un stylo, et elle écrit sur ce post-it.
Puis elle revient s'asseoir à côté de moi.
...Moi j'suis toujours dans ma paralysie !
A ce moment-là, certains sont dans leur jacuzzi, moi j'suis dans ma paralysie ! Ok ?
Mais la vraie paralysie !
Après m'être pris 18 coups de coudes dans les côtes
je comprend que ce qu'elle a écrit sur ce post-it, ça m'est destiné !
Alors je me lève, toujours dans ma paralysie.
Ce qui donne quelque chose comme ça :
Je prend le post-it dans mes petits doigts d'enfant très doux.
Et j'y lis : Lucas, je t'aime...
Ohh ! Bah là, mon coeur, mon pote, il est.. On est sur un beat.. Euh.. Africain !
[Musique africaine]
J'écris sur le deuxième post-it, la chose suivante : moi aussi Audrey
[Musique de type métal]
Voilà ce qu'il y a à ce moment là, dans ma case thoracique, voilà !
Je retourne m'asseoir à côté d'Audrey ! Toujours sans la regarder !
On est là pour embrasser un post-it à la fin ! Ah non, Audrey on s'en fout, on a pas les couilles !
Et là, après trois minutes, elle se décide à aller voir ce que j'ai écris.
Puis elle revient, attention.. Sans avoir écrit quoi que ce soit.
[Musique d'intrigue]
A quoi tu joues, Audrey ?
Là, petite goûte de sueur sur la tempe.
Peut-être aurait-elle préférée que je lui dise "Moi j't'aime pas, mais starfulah !"
Mais ce n'est pas le cas !
Poil : "Eh Lucas, fait pas ton boloss ! Écrit que tu veux la smacker, et tout !"
Oh putain, mais le conseil du poil, mec !
Je vais sur le post-it, comme ça, j'suis deter.
Je sors mon stylos, en mode, Kira de Death Note !
Et je note la chose suivante : on s"embrasse, point d'interrogation
*rot*
Faut juste retirer le rot.. Au montage, Clément.
Et là, elle se retourne vers moi, et elle fait ça :
[Musique romantique]
Cet instant dura à la fois une seconde, et à la fois dix mille années !
Je n'ai que très peu de temps pour prendre une décision, et je prend la meilleure décision qu'il soit.
[Musique de réussite]
C'était, le premier smack, de ma vie.
Wow! Merci à tous! [Acclamation de foule] C'était aussi le dernier mais faut pas le dire !
C'est la fin de cette première anecdotes, j'espère qu'elle vous a plu.
Je voulais vous raconter ça, parce que je trouve que c'est important.
La première fois, où on a osé faire un bisou à une fille.
Et moi je suis content, parce que ça c'est passé de la manière la plus mignonne qu'il soit !
On était mignons, Audrey ! Faut se le dire !
J'espère qu'après ça tu as trouvé l'amour de ta vie, et qu'il a fait sa demande en mariage en écrivant sur des post-its ! *rire*
Bon, là, ça critique et tout, alors que ça a cliqué, mais comment ça s'est passé, vous, votre premier bisou avec une fille ?
Bah, dites-moi en commentaire !
J’épinglerai le meilleur !
En vrai j'espère que ça s'est bien passé pour vous, peu importe la technique que vous avez eu !
Moi c'était les post-its, il y en a c'était peut-être.. La feuille A4 ?
Ou alors il y en a qui y sont allé cash, et qui ont fini au commissariat car la fille n'était pas consentante
aaaaaah ! : p
Bref, c'est le moment de la deuxième anecdote ! Qui est tout l'inverse de la première, à savoir, elle n'est pas glamour du tout !
Elle est dégueue, elle est horrible !
Je l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois, mais je le répète. Quand j'étais plus jeune, j'allais un Week End sur deux chez mon papa.
Cette année là, j'avais douze ans, vous savez très bien à quoi je ressemblais à douze ans. On l'a vu la dernière fois ensemble.
Je portais des costumes-cravates trop grand, comme actuellement !
Et, on avait mangé des noix de Saint Jacques avec mon papa.
Et puis j'étais partie me coucher vers minuit.
A 3h30 du matin, j'ouvre les yeux et je me sent mal. Très mal.
Je sens la sueur couler le long de ma tempe.
Je me dis : "Oulala, il y a un problème."
Je me lève de mon lit. Et là, j'ai le besoin d'évacuer. Ce qui pose problème à mon corps.
C'est une manière polie pour dire que je béger sa mère sur la moquette mon gars, mais vraiment puissant.
Et là je prend conscience que je suis probablement en train de faire une indigestion, ou qu'il y a un début de gastro. Il y a un truc qui va pas !
Et pendant que je prend conscience de ça, mon intestin et mes fesses prennent conscience d'autre chose.
Du fait qu'elles ont besoin, elles aussi, d'évacuer.
Mais elles me préviennent pas !
Alors pendant que je vomis.. Je me chie dessus, voilà.
C'est bon, je l'ai dis, c'est passé.
Moment terrible, ça arrive très peu de fois dans une vie après tes douze ans, mais quand ça arrive.. Tu as un seum incroyable.
Je me dirige alors, aux toilettes, pour vérifier si ce qu'il vient d'arriver, est vraiment arrivé.
Oh que oui, c'est arrivé !
Je vais alors dans la salle de bain, et je retire mon caleçon, pour le nettoyer.
Etant donné que, ça sent très fort !
Je suis.. Nan mais désolé ! Mais je vous dis.. Attendez ! La suite est moins crade, mais juste pour vous..
Là faut que je vous mette dans le contexte, donc c'est la pire situation, quoi.
Pourquoi j'suis traumatisé ? Parce que, quand ça t'arrives ça, t'as vraiment pas envie que quelqu'un te voit.
Et que ça se sache que tu t'ai chié dessus.
Alors qu'en soit, il y a rien de grave. C'est juste que t'es malade, ça arrive.
C'est pas grave !
Bref ! Le lavabo, change de couleur, littéralement.
Et à droite, dans cette salle de bain, il y avait une fenêtre.
Mais c'est une fenêtre où c'est trouble, on voit pas à travers.
J'avais peur que quelqu'un ouvre cette fenêtre et fasse : "haha ! Tu t'es chié dessus !"
Ce qu'est un peu improbable, on va pas se mentir !
Il s'est passé pire ! Bien pire !
Il y a une main qui vient se coller contre la fenêtre, hyper fort !
J'ai clairement failli me rechier dessus.
Vraiment ! J'ai eu peur ! J'ai sursauté !
Ma belle-mère, donc la copine de mon père. A deux filles, et ces deux filles, étaient bien plus âgées que moi
et elles sortaient, le samedi soir. Et elles revenaient de boîte de nuit, un peu alcoolisées.
Et j'entends l'une des deux dire : "Bah enfin qui c'est qui est dans la salle de bain à cette heure là ? Ca doit être Lucas, on va lui dire bonjour !"
[Musique d'intrigue]
Oh là, non !
Je m'empresse de verrouiller la porte de la salle de bain.
Là, mec. J'ai jamais lavé aussi vite un vêtement de toute ma vie.
Il y avait de l'eau partout ! Sur les murs, sur les serviettes.
Elles viennent toquer à la porte de la salle de bain.
Soeur : "Qui c'est qu'est là ? Tu fais quoi ?"
Mais laisse-moi tranquille ! Laisse-moi dans ma merde !
A proprement parlé ! Est-ce que je te demande toi qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?!
Bref.
A ce moment-là. J'aurais adoré avoir un post-it sous la main pour lui glisser sous la porte et marqué dessus :
Mais j'avais pas de post-it ! Alors d'une voix fébrile, je réponds ;
"Je me.. Je me sent pas très bien, mais tout va bien !"
Mais qu'elle erreur..
Il fallait juste que je me brossais les dents !
Mes demies-soeurs étant bienveillantes, me propose leur aide.
- T'as b'soin de quelque chose ?
- Tu veux qu'on te ramène une serviette ?
- On attends d'vant la porte au cas où !
Mais cassez-vous !
Vous allez pas camper d'vant la porte ! Vous allez me voir ressortir avec une odeur de merde là, putain !
Bref. Après vingt minutes, elles vont dans leur chambre.
Je déverrouille la porte. Je sprint jusqu'à mon lit.
Et j'oublie quelque chose qui s'est passé. Peu avant.
Sur ma course retour, vers, mon lit.
Je marche, dans mon vomis.
Et là je n'ai plus le choix, je dois allez voir mes demies-soeurs en leur demandant une serpillere.
Car je ne savais pas où elles étaient.
Je nettoie alors le vomis. Je me recouche.
Et dix ans plus tard, je vous raconte cette histoire, en vidéo.
Merci beaucoup ! Celle-là elle est pour tout ceux qui se sont chié dessus un jour !
Bon, l'anecdote suivante !
Les amis, il y a quelque chose dont j'ai profondément honte. Et que j'aimerai avouer. Et m'excuser auprès de la personne concernée.
Comme vous le savez très bien puisque je n'arrête pas de vous le préciser à chaque vidéo, autant ça m'a marqué. Je jouais énormément à Dofus quand j'étais plus jeune.
Dofus est je le répète un RPG, donc le but c'est de passer des niveaux, d'avoir les meilleurs équipements, d'avoir de l'argent pour acheter les meilleurs équipements.
Tout ça, tout ça.
Mais le petit Lucas qui a dix ans. Bah ! Il veut gruger le système !
Il veut pas en chier lui ! Il veut que les gens lui donnent des choses, hein !
Au moment de créer mon personnage, je choisi un personnage féminin.
Et je choisi aussi à ce moment présent, de devenir une fille.
*rire* Vraiment !
J'avais un dédoublement de la personnalité. Quand je jouais, j'étais Lucie. Et quand je ne jouais plus, j'étais Lucas.
Mais attention ! Quand je dis devenir Lucie, c'est vraiment tout ce que ça implique !
C'est que j'écrivais de la même manière, je faisais les mêmes choses qu'elles !
Mesdames, je vous ai copiées !
Je mettais des p'tits smileys mignons en fin de phrase, je faisais gaffe à ne faire aucune faute d'orthographe.
Alors que j'étais nul à chier en orthographe !
Je faisais genre que je savais pas des trucs évidents, pour que les garçons trouvent ça mignon, et m'offrent quelque chose.
Peut-être dans l'espoir d'avoir mon numéro, je sais pas !
J'étais diabolique !
Très rapidement, je rencontre un confrère, Ecaflip. Lui, avait un perso' masculin, donc je me suis dit : "Ok, c'est un mec."
Let's go !
On va jouer de nos charmes ! Qui n'existent pas dans la vraie vie.
Pour essayer d'avoir, du minerai et de l'argent !
Ah, j'étais une michto ! J'ai la petite michto de Dofus !
*rire*
Bref. Je lui parle, et, il me donne du fer. Sympa.
Il m'emmène XP. Encore plus sympa.
Il me donne de l'équipement. Colossalement sympa.
Et tout ce petit cinéma, dure, pendant plusieurs semaines.
Même moi, j'commençais à m'attacher au mec, gros !
C'était avant l'histoire des post-it et d'Audrey, donc j'me met à douter et j'me dis : "Putain, si ça se trouve, en fait, j'aime les hommes !"
Mais non. J'aimais tout simplement. Le pouvoir.
*rire* A 10 ans !
En plus de jouer à Dofus ensemble, le but principal de notre intéraction à la base.
La personne veut qu'on parle, sur MSN.
Sur MSN, la personne, met sa webcam. Et en fait.
C'était une fille.
C'était une fille. Lesbienne. Et comme je me faisais passer pour une meuf, eh ben.. Elle était tombée un peu amoureuse de moi.
Eh mec, j'm'en voulais tellement que j'savais plus quoi faire.
J'avais 10 ou 11 ans, donc c'était il y a vraiment longtemps mais ça m'a fait trop mal au coeur.
Elle commençait à me raconter ses problèmes, j'commençait à.. L'aider à les résoudre.
J'étais impliqué dans sa vie, vraiment !
J'avais télécharger un logiciel qui permettait de passer des vidéos comme si t'avais une webcam en fait.
Donc je mettais des vidéos de filles.. Normales hein. Pas dénudées ou j'sais pas quoi.
Mais pour qu'elle croit que c'était moi en fait, sur ces vidéos-là.
Et elle y croyait de fou.
Et c'est juste, je m'enfonçais dans mon mensonge car j'voulais pas faire de mal à cette personne.
Ecoutez, un jour j'me rattrape, je prends conscience de tout ça. Et j'veux que ça cesse.
Alors j'lui donne rendez-vous au dessus du zaap d'Astrub.
*rire*
Et je lui dit :
Oh le mec il a pas de couille ! Il ose pas lui dire !
Et là, elle me répond :
"Mais bon, pas grave, tant qu'on continue de se parler sur MSN. :)"
[Musique stressante]
Lucas : "Ah."
Lucas : "Et je n'aurais pas Internet."
Pire excuse.
Fille : "Mais, comment je vais faire, moi, sans toi ? :("
J'appuie alors sur la touche Echap.
Je clique alors sur "Se déconnecter" !
Puis je vais sur MSN, et je la supprime !
Puis je ne lui ai plus jamais parlé !
J'ai honte !
J'suis désolé.
Je sais pas qui tu es, je sais pas si tu vas bien ou pas.
Mais.. J'suis désolé. *rire*
J'étais jeune ! J'étais con !
Et surtout.. Je voulais du pouvoir, dans Dofus ! *rire
Je voulais gagner mes duels ! Et rien ne se mettait en travers de ma route !
*soupire*
Oh.. Quelle connerie.
Ne faite jamais ça, c'est débile.
On s'en rend peut-être pas compte, mais les gens s'attachent, même virtuellement.
Et je m'en rendais pas compte à cette époque là.
Alors soyez pas des gros cons. Faîtes pas comme moi.
Parce que ça a du vraiment la blesser. Si ca se trouve elle en a souffert pendant grave longtemps.
Ou alors, si ça se trouve, grâce à ça, elle s'est confiée à quelqu'un d'autre, et c'est devenu, sa copine.
Et, elles sont très heureuses. Et elles se sont mariées, même. Peut-être. J'espère.
Les amis ! C'est la fin de cette vidéo ! Les anecdotes de Squeezie #2 !
J'espère qu'elle vous a plu ! Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer, comme d'habitude !
J'adore raconter des anecdotes. Ca me fait rire.
C'est des trop bons souvenirs. Même quand c'est un truc douloureux.
Bah avec le temps, ça devient un truc rigolo.
Comme la dernière fois ! N'hésitez pas à me dire dans les commentaires des trucs qui vous sont arrivés.
Si vous avez des anecdotes comme ça, croustillantes. Racontez-nous la plus croustillante dans les commentaires !
Et surtout ! Racontez-nous comme ça s'est passé la première fois que vous avez fait un bisou à une fille !
Moi j'veux savoir ! C'est rigolo ! C'est tellement de pression ! Et tout, quand t'es jeune de faire ça.
Que ça donne toujours des histoires amusantes en général.
Ou alors il y a que moi qui était un putain de looser à écrire sur des post-it, et tous les autres ça s'est bien passé !
Je ne sais pas !
Si vous êtes un post-it et que vous regardez cette vidéo, j'vous aimes, voilà. Sachez-le, vous m'avez sauvé la vie, ce jour-là.
Allez à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo !
Oh ?! Balle au prisonnier !
[Pleurnichement]
[musique d'outro]